So our next segment will
contain two speakers
speaking about data in
astrophysics as well
as data in genomics.
The first speaker
will be speaking
about the Open Data Challenge
in Computational Astrophysics.
Dr. Daisuke Nagai is
an associate professor
of physics and astronomy
at Yale University
and the faculty
co-director of the Yale
Center for Research Computing.
His current research focuses on
theoretical and computational
modeling of the
structure formation
of the universe and its
application to cosmology.
He obtained his PhD from the
University of Chicago in 2005.
It was the Sherman Fairchild
Postdoctoral Scholar
at the California
Institute of Technology
before he joined the
Yale faculty in 2008.
Welcome, Dr. Nagai.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
Well, thank you very
much for the invitation.
It's a pleasure to actually talk
about some of the perspectives
that we're actually learning
from the computational
astrophysics area.
So I would like to start.
I think this is a really
exciting time in science
where we might be actually going
through some sort of paradigm
shift in science.
If you look back in the
history, science has been--
over a long time, the
thousands of years,
it's mostly the
empirical studies
of describing natural
phenomena by collecting data.
There was a paradigm shift
several hundred years ago
when the theoretical
branches arose
where Isaac Newton
actually started
to use mathematical formulations
to actually describe
laws of nature and tried
in the hope of describing
the empirical data that the
astronomers were collecting.
And that opened up
that theoretical branch
several hundred years
ago and since then, we've
seen the emergence of this
field of physics, which
has identified several
laws of physics
from electromagnetism
to gravitational physics
to quantum theory,
which has been
teaching us a lot about the
physical laws of nature.
But in the last few
decades, we have actually
seen another emergence
of a new technique.
This is the
computational branch.
And then today, due to the
emergence of computation,
that's actually starting to
produce a large amount of data
that this is maybe
a new paradigm
shift that maybe the data is
actually telling us something.
And this new shift
actually requires new ways
of thinking to do science.
The computation permeates
throughout the society,
starting all the way from the
smallest scales of on particle
physics all the way
up to the structure
formation of the universe.
And everything
happens in between,
from molecular dynamics
and applications
to drug discovery to
looking for fusion research
in the hopes of actually
finding clean energy--
car safety.
These days, in order to study
the safety of an automobile,
we no longer actually
crash the car
but we do computational
simulations
to get insights into how to
actually build a safer car.
If you want to
actually train a pilot,
we would actually use
the flight simulator
to actually train
the pilot instead
of having them actually fly
on the actual physical plane
and so forth.
And on the much larger
scale, the weather forecast,
planet formation,
galaxy formation,
and large-scale
structure formation,
these are the phenomena that
are very difficult to actually
study and the
computation approach
has been really revolutionizing
the way we actually
understand those systems.
So using computation,
what we're actually doing
is actually trying to
give a complete evolution
of the physical
system, where you have
a parameter that you can vary.
And we are starting to do the
experiment using computers.
And this is sort of the new
way of actually doing science
and as the computer
gets faster and faster,
the data is growing with
an exponential rate.
And with that larger
data, it's even
starting to change
how we actually
think about the science.
Typically, we
develop a hypothesis
and go out and collect the
data to test the hypothesis.
But however, when you
have so much data,
you can start to think about
whether the data can actually
teach us something
that we don't know.
Could the data teach
us more about the ideas
that we could generate?
Those are possibilities
that were potential
that is actually making us
making this field particularly
exciting.
Data is becoming
increasingly open and public
and the fact that the
data is everywhere
is actually bringing people
from physical sciences
to life sciences
to medical sciences
together, connected through
statistics and computing.
So we might actually be
in this rare opportunity
where we can actually
exploit this paradigm shift
and what comes out
is I think what
we're here to actually discuss.
How can we actually make
this feel the most fruitful
as possible?
And my area of astrophysics
has been inherently
and traditionally data-driven
because we cannot do
experiments on the universe that
we are interested in knowing.
So what's on the left-hand side
is the Planck Satellite mission
that's in space observing
the universe in microwaves.
What's on the right-hand side
is the Sloan Digital Sky Survey
studying the galaxies'
distributions in optical.
And I sort of think of this
as a cosmic genome project,
where we are actually mapping
out the distribution of mass
in the entire universe.
In the microwave, you can study
about the distribution of mass
in the very early phase
of the universe, where
the universe was very smooth.
And what's shown on
the right-hand side,
the pictures of distributions
of galaxies in the entire sky,
is actually showing the
universe is very clumpy--
very homogeneous.
There are regions with
a very high density
concentration of
galaxies and there
are regions with empty voids.
And so we have a snapshot
of how the universe evolved
from the very smooth state
to a very clumpy state.
But in this field, we
also know the physical law
that's governing the devolutions
of this physical system.
On the largest possible scale,
the gravity is a dominant force
and we have a working model
of the gravitational laws
developed by Einstein.
So here, what we're
doing is we're
taking the map that we
see in the early universe
from the cosmic
microwave background
as an initial condition.
You can then set that
initial condition
and solve Einstein's
equation forward in time
and you should be
able to reproduce
the distribution of
a clumpy universe
in the present-day universe.
So this is what has been
done and it actually
generates the universe that
consists of the gravitationally
bound objects like galaxies
and clusters of galaxies.
And also, there are
empty regions like voids,
as we see in the data.
So what we're really
doing, modern astrophysics
is really the nexus of the
big data and supercomputing.
On one side, we have a
telescope as an instrument which
is taking data,
taking a snapshot
at any given point in space.
But however, on
the left-hand side,
we have the
high-performance computer.
It also acts as an instrument.
In fact, we do most of
the experiment where
we vary the [? knobs ?] in using
this high-performance computer.
Both of these instruments
generate a huge amount
of data, which has to be
analyzed through the data
analysis pipeline.
You use statistics
to actually compute
the relevant
statistical quantity.
You glue those
information together
through the statistical
framework of Markov chain Monte
Carlo and then try
to infer things
like what the universe
actually consists of.
Today, we believe the
universe that best
fits the observation actually
consists of the 4% of stuff
that we knew about.
These are matters,
protons, and electrons.
And it turns out that
this 96% of the stuff that
fills the universe
is made out of things
that we didn't know about.
This field of studying the
universe in this kind of way
has really taught us that
all the physics that we
knew until the last century only
made up 4%, really opening up
a new avenue for
discovering what's
the nature of dark
matter, what's
the nature of dark energy,
what is the universe made of,
and where we are going.
Now, to do this, on
the left-hand side,
on the computational
modeling, there
are different types of code
available to actually model
the physical evolutions
of the universe.
And here, I'm showing the
six different types of code.
All of these are solving
the same set of equations
by using different techniques.
Some are representing
the distribution of mass
as a particle.
Some represent the distribution
of mass as a grid and cells
and you solve the same set of
equations in different ways.
And so in order to actually
test how the code is actually
working, you try to use
the different types of code
and solve the same problem.
This is a simple problem where
you have a gas blob moving
in a tenuous medium and you
use the five different codes
to actually solve the
exact same problem.
And the interesting thing--
well, the problem
here is that depending
on what kind of code or
algorithm that you use,
the evolution of
this physical system
produces different results.
So this is sort of the
reproducibility crisis
that we are facing
in astrophysics,
that the computational
results do
depend on code and algorithm.
So for any given algorithm, you
can reproduce the same results.
But although you're
solving the same problem,
if you're solving them
using a different technique,
it could result in
different results.
Here is a slightly more
complicated situation
where we're using the 12
different types of code.
So for computational
astrophysics, what's important
is to do this thing called
"a code comparison project."
You need to develop
different types of approaches
for solving the same
problem and starting
with the exact same
initial condition
and trying to solve a slightly
more complicated problem,
in this case, the formation
of galaxy clusters,
the most massive
objects in the universe.
So here's an
attempt back in 1999
where the 12 simulators
got together and decided
to simulate the same
thing, since they were not
agreeing among
themselves on the results
that they were getting
on the same problem.
And you can see the
distributions of gas
in these massive
galaxy clusters and you
can see more or less that
they actually form something.
They are a spherical blob
but there are clearly
some differences, too.
What's more notorious
here is here,
I'm plotting these distributions
of gas as a function of radius
and the results actually
agree fairly well
at the very large radii.
But there are
notable differences
in the inner region,
depending, again, on the code.
Whether you use grid-based
or particle-based code,
you get systematically
different results.
So this kind of
comparison can actually
teach us about the pros and
cons of different techniques.
So the scientific results,
especially computational
results, must be not
only reproducible
but it would also
have to be accurate.
This also raises the
question as to how
do we actually know
that we are converging
on the right answer, which
is also important, as well.
Now, the reproduces challenges--
so so far, I talked about
how to run a simulation.
Using different types of code,
you get different results.
The computational
astrophysics involve
fairly complex workflow, where
you have to go through and take
the simulation out,
put the visualized in,
then analyze through many,
many layers of steps.
First, identify the object
that you are interested in.
How you define the object--
how do you actually
analyze the data?
There are fairly
complicated algorithms
that go through the
process those outputs
of that simulation and then go
through the analysis pipeline.
Finally, plot the results
of the interested quantity.
So the complex workflow--
we also need to identify the
different types and levels
of reproducibility and accuracy
in this research process
in order to get
the robust results.
So in this process, most of
the intellectual contributions
and assets actually are
encoded in that code, which
consists of two
things, an algorithm
that we use to actually
develop our software
and the software itself.
So the code is where most of
the intellectual contributions
are and then the
additional contribution
lies in the workflow of
the code that interconnects
between different types of
code at different stages
of the research.
Some of the solutions are
specific to a research
community, such as
algorithms and software.
However, there are
also common solutions.
Those include the software
sharing and preservation,
which we use GitHub and
Bitbucket to actually do
that software
development as a team--
also with the scientists
around the world.
And in terms of data sharing,
we use Globus Online extensively
to disseminate the
outputs of the simulations
and share them around with
scientists around the world.
The data science
policy is another area
where there are
some commonalities
among the researchers
who do research
on different disciplines.
Those include the e-journals,
funding agencies--
infrastructure are some of
the things that we share.
Even though you're
trying to actually solve
a different problem, there are
things that we can actually
coordinate.
So the Yale Center for
Research and Computing
can actually address some
of these issues that are
common among the researchers.
And those include the
cyber infrastructure,
such as HPC and storage,
software, education,
and training and grant
support and community
outreach, including day of data
and organizing and bringing
researchers together from
the different disciplines
to actually talk about the
data or things that are common.
In this way, we can
improve the efficiency
and actually exchange the
different techniques that
are used and different ideas.
And I think this
is the way forward
in terms of making the
transformative impact
in different fields.
So let me just
conclude by saying
that both reproducibility
and accuracy are
important for credibility
of any science.
Open data and open
code are certainly
the important solution.
Or in our computational
astrophysics,
we are also learning that
the algorithm and software
development is an
equally important aspect
of doing science in this area.
And we can use
combinations of those
as a basis for
data-driven science
hopefully in the future.
Some of the solutions are
specific to the research
community or even sometimes to
the group, code development,
process, and workflow.
In this area, the
discipline-specific data
scientists can actually
play a very important role
in developing and in optimizing
some of these software
development and also the
efficiency of the process
and the workflow.
Some of the other
solutions that are
more common among the
different research communities
include HPC infrastructure,
software, and data and code
sharing.
And those are the
things that the Yale
Center for Research and
Computing will be able to help.
However, there is
some missing gap
that I notice as
we actually develop
trying to figure out
what kind of research
should be done within our own
group-- what kind of things
should we actually
coordinate and do it
as a part of the community.
Another important
thing that we are
starting to realize
in our research
is the algorithm development.
As you develop a code,
as I highlighted,
the computational
results could actually
depend on not just what
problem you're solving
but how you're
solving that problem.
And we sometimes do not know.
Basically, the problem
that we are facing
is that you're solving
the same set of equations
and it's well-tested by
solving the problem that we
know the answers to.
But we're taking that
code and extrapolating it
to the region where we don't
know how well the code actually
performs.
Different types of algorithms
have pros and cons so
when you actually extrapolate
the code into the regime
where we haven't tested--
but this is the
whole point of doing
the computational modeling is
that that opens up solutions
to some of the problems that
have not been solved before.
But it's actually difficult
to convince ourselves,
how do we know
that we're actually
converging to the true answer?
Given the code, you can
reproduce the results.
But if you use different
code, you actually
find two different results.
In the case of the
galaxy cluster where
we see differences in the
grid-based and particle-based
code, there is a long debate
about which one is actually
the right solution.
We just get the two
different solutions
and we don't know which one
is the correct solution.
The problem is very serious
because the comparison--
I show two comparisons.
Those are separated by 15 years.
We're still debating
about the same problem
after 15 years of research.
And this has to do with
the-- and the only way
we can move forward is the
independent development
of different types of
code, different types
of algorithms, and
then the community
has to convince themselves a
better understanding of pros
and cons, the characterization
of the code algorithm,
is actually the way forward in
actually getting a true answer
from computational astrophysics.
And this is important
because we're
using computational
models to infer
some important results,
such as the composition
and origins of the universe.
And if we're using the wrong
models to actually interpret
the data where we cannot
do the experiment,
we will be inferring
the wrong results.
So this is one area that
I think we would need--
to actually make a real
impact, we need not just the--
it's important to actually make
the data and code available.
But it's also important to
think about these issues
of the accuracy and how we
actually convince ourselves
that results we're getting
are the right answer.
So let me stop here and
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Dr. Nagai.
We will have Q&A for both
speakers of this segment
at the end of this
second speaker.
Our next speaker,
Arif Harmanci, will
be discussing the quantification
of private information leakage
from genomic data sets.
Dr. Harmanci received his
PhD from the University
of Rochester in 2011.
He joined the
Gerstein Lab at Yale
as a postdoctoral
researcher in 2011, as well,
and since then has been
working on the development
of analytical tools for
bioinformatics research.
His primary focus is on
functional genomics data
analysis.
Can we copy this?
We didn't put it in yet.
[INAUDIBLE] wanted a copy.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Open.
Yes.
Maybe [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
OK.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Right.
Hi, everyone.
It's a great
pleasure to be here.
I want to thank the organizers
for giving me this opportunity.
So I'm going to switch
gears a little bit
and I'm going to talk about
computational privacy.
It may get a little
bit technical
but I'll try to get through
it as easy as possible.
So yeah, the title
is "Quantification
of Sensitive Information
Leakage in Phenotype Data."
So let me try to give you
guys a brief context here.
So privacy is obviously
very important.
And as we do more open science
and we share more data,
one problem that
is going to come up
is a lot of different
data sets that
contain sensitive information
or personal information,
that they can be
linked together.
And if you think about
an adversarial person,
he may go and fetch
those data sets
and well, he can invade privacy.
So I guess one thing that
we will need to think about
in the next several
years is going
to be how we can
quantify the risks
and what's the
sense of information
leakage in these datasets.
It's not a solved
problem at all.
We need to think about
it really carefully.
And actually, NIH wants to
push data sharing a lot more
in the next several years.
And actually, yesterday, I don't
know if you guys follow it.
There was this 21st Century
Cures passed through the House
and actually, that
gives NIH the incentives
to actually make researchers put
their data in the central data
commons that NIH is
actually planning to produce
in a couple of years.
So these are going to be
real challenges that we
will face in a couple of years.
And I would want to
start with this example
that we like to present.
It has nothing to
do with genomics.
So there was this
Netflix price challenge
that this Netflix company--
I'm sure you guys know about it.
It's the movie rental
company where these guys,
they wanted to improve their
movie recommendation systems.
And what they did was from the
huge database of movie ratings,
they extracted this
training dataset
which consisted of these users.
Well, these are real people.
Well, their names are
obviously de-anonymized.
And there were these movies
and what this guy rated this,
when did this guy rate this
movie, and this movie's rating.
So higher is better.
Lower is worse.
And the idea was the researchers
would take this training
data set, build machine
learning models,
and they would then
test these models
on another testing data set
where the rating is taken out
so that Netflix can go
and cross-validate and see
who wins.
And the prize of this
challenge was $1 million
so it was a pretty
serious thing.
And it went on for
three years, I think.
And let me talk about
this dataset a little bit.
So there are 100 million
ratings for 400,000 users.
On average, each user rated
200 movies and each movie
was rated by 5,000 individuals.
And it turns out this
was not a very good idea
because these researchers,
Narayanan and Shmatikov,
they actually showed that
you can take this Netflix
dataset which was anonymized
and you can actually
go to another completely
different movie dataset, IMDB,
and you can actually link these.
And using pretty
straightforward techniques--
I won't go into the
details of those--
you can actually
identify who a lot
of the people in Netflix's
dataset, their identities,
taken from the IMDB.
So that was a big problem and
actually, Netflix got sued
and they had to pay a
pretty big price for this.
And well, there are four
basic things to note here.
So the reason why this
attack happened firstly was
these are very big datasets.
So if you think
about it, if somebody
has an account on Netflix,
there is a very good likelihood
that he or she is going to
have an account on IMDB.
And a lot of the users,
they rate a movie.
For example, you watch a movie.
Then you would wait
around the same time
and you would give
similar ratings
and these researchers actually
statistically showed that.
Well, actually, they also
did the actual attack
but they showed that
statistically, you
can link any very big dataset
with a lot of features
to each other.
So it wasn't a very
good idea, after all.
Going into this
phenotypic problem,
phenotype-genotype
linking problem
that we have, the way we
are thinking about this
is we have a lot of
phenotype datasets.
These can be your
electronic health records
or it can be a lot of
molecular phenotypes, like gene
expression levels, metabolimics,
proteomics, and any "omics"
that you can think about.
And there are these
genotype datasets
which you might have
gotten in 23andMe
or some ancestry website
or your hospital.
These are going to get very,
very relevant to our health
system.
And what we are
thinking is going
to be very relevant to
what an adversary does
is linking these datasets
because recently, I
think 23andMe, they announced
that they genotyped their 1
millionth customer.
So they have millions of
people in their database
and there's a very
high likelihood
that the guy who
gets their genotypes
measured in 23andMe, they're
going to go and do it
in ancestry.com, too,
because a lot of people
like doing this stuff.
But the 23andMe and ancestry.com
don't know about each other.
So if a hacker goes and
hacks these two datasets,
there is a very good likelihood
that he can go and link them
with another data set that
he gets from a hospital
or somewhere.
So in our case,
what's happening is
we have the phenotype
dataset, the genotype
dataset-- these are
independently served.
So the genotype there,
we're assuming it's hacked.
And if a phenotype
dataset is anonymized,
we have these just IDs and
very sensitive information--
for example, HIV status--
and a lot of phenotypic
measurements.
So these phenotyping
measurements are some numbers.
It can be your gene expressions.
It can be your height.
It can be your
blood glucose level
or some other measurement.
And these are
variants so "0, 1, 2"
means you are a reference allele
or heterozygous or homozygous
alternate.
So don't worry about those.
But these are basically three
valued levels of your genotypes
at certain positions
in your genome.
And there are these
public datasets called
"phenotype-genotype
correlation" they assess.
So what's given
here is a phenotype
is correlated to a variant.
So for example, the position
in your genome changes
and your eye color changes.
So if I look at your eye color--
this is green--
I have a very good idea of what
your variant in that position
is going to be.
And then what we are
saying is you can actually
do a genotype prediction using
these correlation datasets
because I can go from
this phenotype measurement
to this variant.
But this step is
stochastic so there's
going to be some errors
that you're making
when you're getting this--
I don't know if you guys
can see the laser pointer--
the predicted variant genotype.
So there's going to be
a lot of errors here.
But the errors actually don't--
the attacker doesn't
care about the errors
that he makes in the genotypes.
He's trying to link this
dataset to this one.
So then what happens is he
does genotype comparison
between these two datasets
and matches the phenotype IDs.
Our genotype IDs are actually
the identifying information
and he gets, referring to
genotype ID, the HIV status.
So at the end of the day,
he linked this genotype ID
to this HIV status and that's
where the damage is done.
So I will focus on these.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to do an example of how easily
this attack can be done.
And I'm going to concentrate on
these things called "expression
quantitative trait loci."
That's a long way of saying the
genotype affects our expression
level.
So here again, on the x-axis,
we have the genotype is 0, 1--
2.
As this value increases or
as you go from the reference
allele to the alternate allele,
your expression level changes.
So you can think about
this like where you have
aa, ac, and cc values here.
So as you change from one
allele to the other one,
your gene expression
level increases
and a variant changes the gene
expression level of a gene.
And so what we want to
do is we want to quantify
how well you can predict.
Like I said before,
there's a stochasticity
in the genotype
prediction process.
So we want to quantify the
predictability to the leakage.
So for the predictability,
what we are looking at
is we have the gene
expression level.
How well can you predict the
genotype from the given gene
expression level?
So we connect this to this
thing called "entropy."
Well, you don't have to think
about it that technically
but basically, higher entropy
corresponds to more randomness.
And it corresponds to lower
predictability and vice
versa for low productivity.
So at the end of the day,
what we are trying to do
is we want to come up with
a metric for predictability.
That is because there
is the stochasticity
in this linkage process.
And then for this
information leakage,
we are basically
asking, let's say
we predicted this
genotype correctly
and how much information
does it give me?
And this is basically
the surprise
of finding this genotype
within the population.
And we formulate this
with this algorithm of 1
over the frequency
in population.
So don't worry
about this formula.
What it's basically saying is
when you have higher genotype
frequency-- for
example, if everybody
has a certain genotype at the
variant in the population,
it wouldn't really
identify anybody.
For example, if I take the
brown-eyed people here,
if I knew some person
was brown-eyed,
I wouldn't really
identify anybody.
But if I knew that one person
is green-eyed-- and usually,
green-eyed is much
less frequent--
than you can actually identify
that person more reliably.
And again, low
genotype frequency
corresponds to high
information content.
So actually, if you take some
data from this 1000 Genomes
Project and do
these computations
for the real EQTLs, these
EQTLs meaning the variants that
correlate with the
gene expression levels,
the leakage unpredictability
is much higher
compared to a shuffled set.
So the metrics that
we're proposing to use
are actually meaningful.
As you can see, they are much
more spread along the diagonal.
And actually, if you can overlay
these allele frequencies,
meaning what is the allele
frequency of that variant
within the population,
then you will
see that actually, the
stuff that is identifying
and that is useful to
an adversary-- that
is, the stuff that gives
you highest leakage and that
is predictable-- is going
to have moderate allele
frequencies.
And as expected, they
have high correlations
with the gene expression levels.
Well, having said
that, it's obvious
that an adversary wouldn't
use-- so the previous plots were
shown for just single EQTLs.
So he would actually
use multiple EQTLs.
So this is where actually
the trade-off comes up.
So as you can see, as
we start from the best
EQTL on the x-axis, we have the
predictability on the y-axis.
We have the leakage.
The best EQTL can be
predicted pretty well at 78%
but it gives you
very small leakage.
As you go up in your EQTL
list, the top two EQTLs,
it gives you 50% predictable.
It gives you more leakage.
And at 5, you can tell there's
20% predictability and seven
bits of leakage.
But as you can see, an
anniversary, what he would do
is start taking these guys--
start using five EQTLs.
But although he's
gaining more information
to identify individuals, he's
actually losing predictability.
So this is where there is a
trade-off between how well you
can predict these
genotypes and how well
you can identify individuals
because of the stochasticity.
So now, moving forward
to how you would really
implement this in
practice, we actually
propose these three steps
of a linking attack.
So the first thing
is you have a person.
What we want to do is we want to
select these phenotypes that we
will use for attack.
Task
And then the next thing is
for the selected phenotypes,
you do a genotype prediction.
And then taking the
predicted genotypes
and using some
auxiliary information,
you can go and link these
and finally estimate
the reliability of how
well you did linking.
So now, I'm going to talk about
this extremity-based genotype
prediction but the
idea is actually
pretty straightforward.
So what we are trying to
do is I take, for example,
my gene expression levels.
So they're my height.
For example, let's say
we have a variant that
correlates with height.
So if I'm very tall
or if I'm very short,
then you can actually say--
these are the extremes
of that phenotype.
Then you would have
a very good idea
of what genotype I have
because as I showed before,
these EQTLs--
actually, for example,
if I'm on top here,
I'm most likely
in this genotype.
Or if I'm here in
the other extreme,
I'm probably 0 for
this variance genotype.
This is similar to if you're
driving a very expensive car.
You're most likely
making a lot of money.
But if you're driving
something not very expensive,
you could be rich or you
may have just middle income.
You may be rich
but you choose not
to drive a very expensive car.
This is a very
similar analogy here.
So what we are
basically proposing
is if you're at the extremes
of these distributions,
you basically assign the
extremes of the genotype.
So you're either rich
or you're very poor,
depending on the car
model you're driving.
So when you use this
genotype prediction
to do this linking attack,
it actually turns out--
so don't worry about this.
This is basically how we
select the EQTLs that we
are using in the attack.
And on the y-axis,
we have the fraction
of vulnerable individuals.
So what this is saying is
if you use all the EQTLs,
you actually get a pretty
good linking accuracy.
So this is for 200 individuals.
And we did a simulation
of 100,000 individuals
and accuracy drops a
little bit but still, it's
very close to 100%.
And actually, if you had
access to that person's gender
or where he or she is
from, like population--
or both at the same
time because gender
is pretty easily predictable
from gene expression levels--
and then you get actually
some improvement.
If you look at here, it's
very much an improvement
but it's very high already.
But at these levels, there's
actually a significant increase
in the accuracy.
So like I said, although this is
getting a little bit technical,
what we are showing here is you
can do these linking attacks
with a very simple approach.
Well, you could basically
actually ask, OK,
this is 70% accuracy if I choose
this cut-off for selecting
EQTLs but which 70%?
For example, I predicted
10 individuals.
Seven of them are right
but only the person
who has the actual phenotypes
knows those seven people.
Is there a way to attack or to
really identify those people?
So actually, there
is a way to do that.
So there is a very
simple metric.
We call this "first
distance gap."
So for example, in our example,
we have 200 individuals.
So I go and link them to the 200
individuals or old individuals
like I have in the
genotype dataset.
And what I do is
for each individual,
I have 200 comparisons.
So what I do is I sort those
200 comparisons with respect
to this genotype
distance and I take
the difference between the
second one and the first one.
And it turns out if you
use this metric to select
these individuals, you can
get a pretty high accuracy.
Here, on the x-axis,
we have sensitivity.
That is how many
of the individuals
in the phenotype dataset
are correctly predicted.
On the y-axis, how many of
the people that he predicted
are correctly predicted?
So depending on this
d 1, 2 threshold,
he can actually select a
very small number to link.
And then it turns
out you can see up
to 40% of the individuals, you
can get 100% accuracy for this.
If he used the whole
dataset, he would get 70%.
But for 40% of the
individuals, you
can actually get 100% accuracy.
So this is 100 individuals
out of 200 dataset.
This is not a small number.
And then these magenta colors
are actually showing you
randomly selected thresholds.
You can see they pretty fastly
converge to the 70% accuracy.
And finally, this actually
doesn't affect only
you but your relatives,
too, because your relatives
have very high correlation
in your genotypes.
That is, I take part
in, for example,
genotyping service of
a company and I get
a phenotype in another company.
They link me but the
linking that they do,
the genotype dataset doesn't
have me but my brother,
for example.
That actually would
put him at risk
so that's what it's showing.
So when you do
linking, actually, it
turns out a majority
of the individuals
that score in the second
rank are the relatives
of the individual.
So actually, when you
take part in a genotype
or a phenotype study, you're
actually putting your relatives
at risk, which actually creates
big, big problems about how
you define consent and
all these, I guess,
complicated issues.
So this is the end
of my presentation.
It was a little bit
technical, I guess.
But if you guys
have any questions,
I can try and answer them.
[APPLAUSE]
In fact, for the questions
I'd, like to call Dr. Nagai up
to the front as
well as Arif so we
can ask the questions of
the two segment speakers.
Yeah.
Sure.
Daisuke-- Daisuke,
astrophysics has always
been at the high end
of the data generation
in computational scale.
You see the field starting
to skimp back on resources
or are they always going to be
the most Pac-Man-like in terms
of aggressively going
after whatever's available?
I think I'm not seeing that
scaling back in the way that--
I think that physics
and astronomy often
and traditionally have
actually pushed the resources
to actually grow.
And for example, the
Large Hadron Collider
is probably the
biggest producer of--
in terms of the amount of
data that it generates,
it's just sort of
redefining and it actually
has pushed the
infrastructure that way.
I think astronomy
continues to do that.
The kinds of
large-scale surveys that
are coming online like LSST,
which is an optical survey
to map out the distributions
of galaxies in the universe,
to SKA, which is the Square
Kilometer Array in radio
there are several dozens of
such surveys coming online only
to produce ever more
exponentially larger
amounts of data per survey.
So this is going
to grow and it's
going to push the envelope of
the production of big data.
And it's going to
define, in terms
of how to deal with
that amount of data,
how to actually build
the network-- how
to do the storage.
I think my guess is that I
think astronomy will continue
to actually experiment at this
sort of frontier of big data
and do different
types of experiments
and I think will help
also other fields
to sort of try to produce
the best practices
from such experiments.
So I'm not seeing
astrophysics dialing back now.
In fact, I see more
growth in terms
of the amount of
data that will be
produced from the
astrophysics community.
So if I understood
your talk correctly,
one of the main
messages is that you
may think you're anonymizing
your data when really, there
are many ways that people can
re-extract that information.
And so I wonder, with all these
initiatives like AllTrials,
where they're really
pushing getting
all these clinical
trial data out there,
are they kind of working into
these protocols a link attack
susceptibility test?
This seems like it should be a
standard part of what they're
doing because it may
not be obvious to them
how they're putting
those patients at risk.
And do you know if there
are any kind of movements
to push that forward?
That's right.
OK.
So let me say something first
before answering your question.
When I do this presentation,
people usually think, like,
we are terrified, OK?
So what do we do about it?
But the idea is not really that.
It's totally the opposite.
So the thing that I think
we really need to understand
is these things--
like, you get up.
You open your window.
You just gave up
some of your privacy
because if somebody
was watching you,
they knew that you
were at your place.
It's just like when you
get out of your house,
somebody can breach
your privacy.
It's just whatever you
do, whatever we do,
whatever data we put
out, it's going to have
some sensitive information.
It's about controlling the risk.
So what we are trying
to come up with here
is it's like we need to
find objective measures.
And NIH is very
interested in that, too.
So we need to find
objective measures
to estimate these
risks and get it
through to scientists and
public because you get consent
from people.
They give their data but
you actually did not really
tell them what are the risks.
Like you said, there are
all these initiatives.
There's actually no
linkability study or something.
That's exactly what we were
thinking for the next step.
I think to be honest, we
need a centralized way
to measure these things.
And we are doing open
science-- open data.
That's good but you
need to also give people
a perspective about what could
happen, what are the risks,
and I told you guys
they're 70% predictable.
What does that really mean?
It's really hard to get these
things into people's minds.
But in general,
medicine is like that.
You tell a person,
you have a 55% chance
of developing schizophrenia.
Well, OK, I don't know.
What does that really mean?
So there is a big challenge and
I don't have the exact answer.
So we need to work
more on that, I guess.
That's my point.
Yeah.
So on the same topic, say
I give my data to 23andMe.
Even if they don't
get hacked, they're
obviously not going to
release all that data
but anything they do release
is going to be giving up
some of my privacy.
So your linkage
study looks at, like,
OK, if we have all of this data
available, what can we connect?
But did you look at at all
what happens if they do a study
and release some
bits of information
and how that can affect an
individual user's privacy?
We didn't do that.
That's a good question.
Well, firstly, I think 23andMe
could release some data
and you just didn't read those
user agreements well enough.
Not you-- but people don't.
Who reads those things?
And I was actually at a
conference a month ago.
There were people
from 23andMe and they
were thinking about how to
open their data to researchers.
So they're working towards that.
And actually, they
should because that
is very valuable data.
There's so much to
be learned from that.
But like I said, going
back, actually, they
should be doing this stuff.
They should be presenting
this stuff to us
because it looks
like they actually--
I don't want to say they don't
know what you're doing but I
think they are still not there.
They know what they're doing
with genotyping and stuff
for sure but it's just we still
don't understand the risk.
And that's a big problem because
right now, the US government is
trying to recruit 1 million
people to get genotyped
and that data is
going to be open.
1 million people--
every 300th person--
is going to be genotyped.
What are the risks behind that?
We don't know.
I have a question about the
data getting more and more big
going into big data.
I saw [INAUDIBLE]
coming by that we're
going from a
hypothesis-driven research
to a data-driven research,
which is, of course, great.
But the risk with that
is having big data,
having a big n number, doing
any kind of correlation
or regression with that,
you will find a correlation
or regression.
The problem in doing that in
astrophysics or in biology
is that we don't know the data
but also not our [INAUDIBLE].
If you have a
certain protein, we
don't know exactly
what that protein
is doing in context of
the cell where it's in
and the part of
cell body it's in.
So what I see coming by a lot
are these lists of things,
for example, proteins with a
hit list of 20 significantly
changed proteins or genes
in a certain disease--
most of the time,
schizophrenia or autism--
and basically without
a proper understanding
how does it work in a network.
And then they put it in a
network and the network is huge
and there's no
understanding for how
that node is affecting another
node far down the network
at all.
So how do you make sure that
researchers are not only
understanding the
data they're using
but also the concept of
the data, your hypothesis,
instead of actually
claiming that they
have a significant result?
Or probably if you collect
that data again, with that end,
number you find way different
kinds of correlations.
So how do you make
sure that quality
that's outputted of this data
is an actual hypothesis--
is an actual kind of answering
to the question instead
of a data-driven approach
that just gives you
a nudge in a certain direction
which is probably wrong?
Who are you asking?
I'm assuming?
Any because both of the research
topics are gathering big data.
Maybe I can comment.
So in astrophysics, we do
not only one experiment
to collect big data.
I think part of the question
here is, how do we know that--
I think there is a complexity in
the process of obtaining data,
such as understanding
a telescope
and how it collects
photons, registers,
and all of every step of
these processes matters.
And the process
of collecting data
is getting ever
more complicated,
not just the data is
growing but that there
is a complexity in the
way you acquire the data.
And one can never
be sure that there
are no flaws in the
process of collecting data
and that creates the
questions about the integrity
of the data that's collected.
Often, what we do
in astrophysics
is to at least do two
or multiple experiments
of the same kind.
And in fact, that's what's
happening in these galaxy
surveys.
There are a half
dozen galaxy surveys
done by different countries.
Instead of joining up and
doing one bigger experiment,
we're keeping them--
especially in astrophysics--
separate, independent
experiments so that you
can do cross-validations
of different results.
And often, the one team
actually claims the discovery
of dark energy and the other
team may actually falsify that.
Or no, but we didn't see it.
So the process of checking
and doing multiple experiments
is especially important.
And this is what's done
often and without actually--
so even within the US when
you do things like cosmic CMB
experiment microwave band,
the NSF is actually--
or it's important that an
agency funds not just one
experiment or one that's
better but to actually think
about supporting multiple
experiments exactly
for this purpose.
And the same goes for
computational astrophysics.
When you do an experiment, we
cannot just rely on one code
that is thought to be superior.
But you would always want
to look for alternatives.
Otherwise, we would not know.
Often, we do not know
that the right answer
because we are solving
this non-linear, very
complicated equation which
we don't know the answers to.
And that's what makes
computation great,
that we can tackle
all of these questions
that we didn't
know how to solve.
But then because we
don't know how to solve,
there's a chance that
one method will not
get that right answer and only
by trying something different
you would know whether you're
converging on the answer.
But there is even a question
as to whether you're actually
converging on the right answer.
That's another deeper level
of questions about whether you
got the right answer.
He said the same
as what you said.
[INAUDIBLE]
No.
In general, when you do
association studies like GWAS--
Genome-Wide Association
Studies-- or these--
I [INAUDIBLE] out
with EQTLs, genotype
to phenotype correlation rather
than a binary correlation.
What people do is they
have a discovery cohort
and the validation cohort.
So obviously, a
discovery cohort is
where you find
these associations
and you go and test.
So there are actually tons
of statistical methods
and they are very strict on how
you find a variant associating
with a phenotype.
And then on top of that,
you go and validate it
in the validation cohort.
And then on top of
that, people usually
do animal models using
these CRISPR or Cas9 assays.
You go and knock down the
gene or you go and change
the variant--
thanks to God now we can do it--
and then see if there is
a corresponding change
in phenotype.
So there is actually a very
strict way to validate it now.
It wasn't there 10
years ago but now
people do it because there were
big problems with GWA studies.
Now, they are much more strict.
And well, this question actually
relates a lot to this topic
because we are
assuming these EQTLs,
those are the variants
that are changing.
The expression levels
or any phenotype
is universally
conserved in all people
and that's not true because
depending on the population,
it's actually these--
for example, anything that
works in a European population
may not work in--
not work but any variant
that changes expression
in a European population
may not change expression
in an African population.
But actually in our study,
I did a lot of tests
like cross-comparisons
between populations
and between different cohorts.
It's pretty well-conserved,
so to speak.
But that's a good question.
These things are
major challenges
for discovery of these.
Yeah.
Just to follow up on
the linkage risks,
so given that you've
shown that there
are these almost insurmountable
or unforeseeable risks, that
becomes a higher and higher
hurdle for researchers
to share data and
make it completely
anonymous and de-identified.
So would you see it as we have
to then accept some threshold
of risk dependent on the data?
So if my user ID for Netflix
then can be linked to me
and people know that I
rated Top Gun five stars,
we say, who cares or versus if
my genotype can be linked to me
and that has some risk if, say,
employers or health insurance
agencies or government is using
that information against me?
So you have to really maintain
a higher threshold there
for acceptable
risk or do we just
have to accept that there's
unforeseeable consequences
and there needs to be
zero, that that should
be the goal is zero risk?
Thanks.
So first, in the Netflix
case, nobody cares about you.
You rated Top Gun five.
But what happens is for
example, there's a lot of stuff
that people don't want to be
revealed about their movie
choices--
not you, not me,
but there are a lot
of people who would
care about that.
So that is where
actually, it's private.
You don't want people
going in there.
You don't want people seeing a
lot of very political movies.
You rated them five or zero.
Or there are a lot
of other things
that could be assumed people
don't want to be seen.
You want to be left alone.
You want it private.
So secondly, I
think yes, we have
to accept that there is risk.
There's always risk when
we put data out there.
But in the consent
forms or something,
you have to firstly objectively
and correctly predict it,
estimate it, and transmit it to
the public in an intuitive way.
Both of these
things are very new.
We don't know how to do it.
There's this
mathematical framework
called "differential privacy."
The computer scientists love it.
It's great.
But if you apply it to
the biological data,
you just don't get
anything out of it.
It doesn't work.
A lot of companies use it.
Google uses it.
Microsoft uses it.
But if you apply it--
people did that.
If you apply it to biological
data-- for example,
the one paper was
actually pretty good.
So they were using this
differential privacy to--
so there's warfarin,
this blood thinner drug.
So actually, it
turns out depending
on how much warfarin
the doctors assign you,
you can go and identify the
patient's genotype for it
pretty certainly for
a certain variant
and you don't want that
to be revealed out.
And the paper basically
used differential privacy
to set the warfarin
dosages but it turns out
those things that were
"private" were killing patients.
So actually, you just lose
all the utility of that data.
So on top of that,
there's another thing.
It's biological utility.
How do you define the
utility of the data?
So there are so many
different factors
that we need to think about
in this area, I guess.
Does that answer it?
So Arif, it sounds
like from what
you're saying that the risk is
in some sense time-dependent,
that the techniques that
one has at your disposal
to compare datasets or
access different datasets
changes over time.
So is there an obligation
upon you as a researcher
to update the consent forms
for people who have given you
samples and offer them
the opportunity to redact
their data from your datasets?
And then going back to
the open data issues
that we've been discussing,
does that then cause impact
on datasets that may have
been released openly in order
to protect the rights and
privacy of the individuals
whose samples are involved?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
That is one of the things
that are very vague,
I guess-- not vague but
it's very hard to define.
Exactly-- there's
the time dependency.
And actually, as a
researcher, no, I
don't want to write that in a
consent form but you have to
because now you will
lose a lot of people.
They wouldn't want
to give their data.
So it's just we need--
I don't know the answer to that.
I guess it should be put there
but how it should be put there
and what should be there I
actually cannot really say
right now.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So both of your areas
are heavily computational
and so there's a lot of
use of software and code
and computation.
And I was at a conference
a couple of years ago
and Tony Hey made a comment
about how in the future,
PIs will be working with
data scientists and software
engineers And that's as much
as they work with grad students
and postdocs now.
So maybe if you can just
comment a little bit
on that aspect of your work, how
much you rely on data science
and computation and how you
see that improve the work
that you're doing and inform.
[INAUDIBLE]
So yeah.
Over the last few years,
we've had graduate students
and students and
postdocs who actually
move into data science.
So we are one of the
producers of data scientists
from physics and
astronomy because what
we do is heavily
computational and skills
that you learn actually are
helpful for the data science
community.
And at the same time,
we need to start
to coordinate with
the data scientists
to help develop various
aspects of the infrastructure
that we need to actually
do science, as well.
So I think this is starting
to happen, that in the past,
I think we have
been sort of losing
the people who were working
in academia to the new--
generate the area
of data science
but then there is now also
the convergence of working
with the data scientists.
And I think there has
to be a partnership
between the university and
data scientists and possibly
this industry to create
the infrastructure.
I think that there was not
a sort of system to actually
sustain the data
scientists within academia,
that it was a new position
and that there was--
but I think it
started to be realized
that this is a very important
part of actually getting
the science done.
So I think that the
situation is gradually
changing that there are new
data science institutes which
can host and develop
the researchers.
And then we have to work
with the data scientists
to actually develop software
and also work on the algorithms.
I envision that
data scientists are
going to be a hub of different
discipline, which I think
data science can work not
just with one discipline
but using some techniques
and data and algorithms.
If they work on
different subdisciplines,
then these are the people
who actually can connect
and they're sort of the nexus of
the knowledge transfer from one
field to another.
And I think this is a way
forward in doing innovations
because, for example, some
of the techniques that we
use in computational
astrophysics
came from engineering.
And that happened 30
years ago and we're still
continuing to use the knowledge
and techniques that we
inherited from other fields.
And this has to happen
at a much faster speed.
And I think that successfully
placing the data scientists
at the nexus of your
computational and data science
research in the future--
and we need to think
very carefully about how
to sort of make that happen.
Yeah.
I agree with everything he said.
I want to add just one thing.
So well, the way I think
about data science,
I still don't have a real exact
definition of it in my mind.
But I would say--
just totally kind
of in parallel but--
85% of the time that we
are spending to do analysis
is just gathering
data, getting rid of--
reformatting it, getting
rid of the noise, the stuff
that you don't need, and
getting to the final thing
that is maybe a data
structure or an Excel file.
It may be something in
your computer memory
but getting to the point
where you can now apply
some machine learning on it.
But the problem is
genomics, at least,
is going to a place where
you just cannot fit something
like--
right now, we have
1,000 Genomes Project.
You had 3 million variants,
2,500 individuals--
gigabytes of memory.
Fine.
But now there's going
to be 30,000 individuals
and then there's going to
be 1 million individuals.
There's just not enough memory.
It just starts going into
what he was going to.
It's going to a place where you
have to do everything either
like HPC-level distributed--
how do you design
those algorithms?
You need a lot of
data scientists,
I guess, for data wrangling,
data cleaning and stuff.
And you need people in
biology that understand
the output of those algorithms.
So it's becoming a really
multidisciplinary science.
And I think the
future is going to be
we are going to do everything
on the clock you know
because there's just
there's no way we
can fit 1 million genomes and
the whole row dataset even
on HPC.
We just don't have
that hardware and we
don't want to have that
hardware because it's
really hard to keep that up.
We go back and forth with
these guys every week.
We piss them off and
then they piss us off.
But I think the
way we have things
is not very
sustainable and yeah,
I think it's going to be
very multidisciplinary
in the future.
I have one more question.
It's a question about CRC--
very happy about that.
And I'm a computational
neuroscientist.
I'm actually quite new
here, hence my accent.
And I looked through the
site and really, well, I
signed up for a couple
of things-- waiting list.
But what would really
help me at the moment
is to have someone or
one on one or a group
to discuss some models,
some computational tactics,
or some data structures.
And I looked through the
website and I couldn't find it.
Maybe I overlooked that.
But is there an initiative
or people planning
to do that as a kind of meet-up?
Over here [INAUDIBLE].
Great.
Thank you.
That's all I want to know.
I'm so glad you brought that
up and I would absolutely
encourage you to reach out to
either Dr. Rob Bjornson or Dr.
Andy Sherman regarding that.
That's why they're here and
they love helping people out.